upset that americans aren't buying into
their massive radical spending bills so
are they looking inward and asking
themselves why their agenda is so
unpopular of course not nancy pelosi
yesterday went after the media blasting
them for not doing the democrats job and
trying to convince the american people
to support the radical proposals
do you think you need to do a better job
at messaging and going forward how do
you sell this if ultimately well i think
you all could do a better job of selling
it to be very frank with you because
every time i come here i go through the
list
family medical leave climate
the issues that are in there and um but
it is true it is hard to break through
when you have such a comprehensive
package
well you know i love the fact that she
says you know do you think that you need
to do a better job of communicating what
our
job is in trying to get this bill passed
so is this now like an open secret dana
is she openly saying that that the media
is a messenger for the democrat well
it's really interesting obviously
republicans have reason to say that the
media is biased but if you ask a lot of
democrats they think the media is biased
against them as well hillary clinton for
sure will tell you that i mean when it
comes to new york times and remember the
clinton global initiative they broke
that story all the emails that kind of
thing so
i would always just recommend this if
you're in the private sector and you
have to hire a pr person always hire a
republican they've definitely had to
work harder they don't think anything is
going to be handed to them they have to
be more persuasive in their language and
more precise in their on the merits
notice that we have not seen the text of
this bill and there's a good reason for
that because as soon as you start
looking into it people are saying wait
we don't really like this it's not a
benign issue
all the polls are saying wait uh well no
we don't really think we need this we
don't think it will help us um and so
they have they're having up here uphill
battle i just want to mention a couple
of things that are in here
just to be clear for people you know
they talk about free child care
one of the things that they would do is
give this gift to the unions and they
would require
all pre-kindergarten providers to have a
college degree
do you think that that will reduce the
cost of child care in america you
already have a childcare price
and they're demanding how much they're
going to get paid they're already aren't
enough child care providers right and do
you need a college degree could you you
know you just don't need to have it the
other thing is it would block
faith-based child care providers from
participating in the program yeah now
that's and that is wrong so that is
where you get the culture war stuff into
these bills they don't have the text out
yet but pay attention to it okay so
geraldo she says only 10 percent know
about what's in the bill and i think
that's but let me finish let me hide her
too but she says but if they knew what
was in their bill she's convinced
americans would support it but take the
example that dana makes about the the
pre-k
what is pre-k i mean i'm i'm all for it
you get the kid and you want them to you
know evolve as much as possible and be
as ready for kindergarten as possible
but pre-k basically is daycare right i
mean in reality so when you insist
that someone has a degree a four-year
degree to babysit your kids
of course it's going to just the you
know lard
expense on it's great
an idea you want pre-k universal pre-k
great but to have a college degree
unnecessary i mean none of my kids ever
had you know that person yeah that and
they they grew up fine they went to
great schools and uh you know not
everybody has to go to college and that
and it's another thing not everybody has
to go to college and and one thing i
just want to say just uh in in my
symbolic role here as progressive i
think that don't you think that uh
cinema and mansion have to be more
specific about what they want in and
what they want out rather than making
people guess about what i think
it's very unfair
i was going to ask greg what will
mansion and cinema fold or will they
will they stick to their guns
i don't know i don't know i just think i
i want to go back to what pelosi said
about the media because it's amazing
that you could say that with a straight
face but that's the advances of modern
medicine greg
is it her fault to expect them to carry
the water i don't think it is she looks
at the media the way you look at that
friend that promises to help you move a
sofa and this is a huge massive sofa and
they have just given up trying to move
it for her and she's like come on you
promised you were gonna move this up the
stairs she looks at the media in a way
that you know they're
they're in the same club she's kind of
right she's kind of right she's right i
do have to say she doesn't bother to
hide her assumption of superiority she
really does see everybody else around
her as like non-playing characters in a
video game like she's playing the game
and everybody else there is just there
to deal with her okay
jessie aoc is actually warning schumer
and pelosi saying you can't get rid of
this this and this so it looks like the
progressives are at war with some of the
mainstream democrats there i mean she's
basically threatening them is she the
leader of that the speaker of the house
well she's got a lot of juice judge and
you know the progressives outnumber the
moderates so she might be a leader in
some regards and the reason that the
media doesn't want to cover the details
of this thing because they know if they
do no one's going to want it because
look at these details 25 million dollars
for butterflies what do they need money
for how about 8 billion for climate
police yes i thought they wanted to
defund the police not the climate police
the climate police how about illegal
aliens get free college tuition
643 million dollars for culturally
appropriate foods what is that taco
tuesday
equity
eight million illegals get amnesty or
they're going to fix racist roads and
bridges that probably just means they
get to demolish statues that they don't
like also millions in grants for
organizations that treat individuals
suffering from loneliness judge
from loneliness
people that are lonely get millions of
dollars and it penalizes marriage
crushing taxes for small business thank
you you're welcome